in der Dämmerung des britischen
Weltreichs Bauten Bänker Anwälte und
Buchhalter aus der Londoner City ein
Spinnennetz von offshore Geheimnissen
auf das Reichtum aus der ganzen Welt
einfing und nach London
schleuste der britische Soldat
überall auf der Welt ist er zu finden
von Gibralta bis
Hongkong überall steht gegen die
drohenden jah
standhaftes Symbol für unseren
gemeinsamen Willen zur Ordnung
[Musik]
Feuer
the spiders
Web Großbritanniens zweites
Empire das britische Empire das größte
Reich das die Welt je gesehen hat über
300 Jahre lang herrschte Großbritannien
seine Armeen eroberten und seine baners
verkündeten die Macht seiner
Währung doch eines Tages begann alles zu
zerfallen ein Land nach dem anderen
erklte Unabhängigkeit von Großbritannien
und keine noch so große Kraft konnte den
Lauf der Dinge aufhalten als die
britischen Eliten sahen wie ihr Reichtum
ihre Privilegien und ihr Imperium
zerfehlen begannen sie nach einer neuen
Rolle in einer sich verändernden Welt zu
suchen und sie fanden sie im
[Musik]
Finanzwesen dieser Film zeigt wie sich
Großbritannien von einer Kolonialmacht
zu einer modernen Finanzmacht wandelte
und wie dieserandel t in der wir leben
geprägt
[Musik]
hat zu Zeiten des britischen Empire war
die City of London das größte globale
Finanzzentrum der
Welt Herz des britischen Empire die
Historiker Kane und Hopkins nannten sie
den Regler des imperialen Motors all
diese Länder im Empire benutzten die
Sterling Währung und die City of London
war sozusagen der Geldgeber nicht nur
innerhalb sondern auch außerhalb der
sterlingzone als das britische Empire
unterging tat es auch die City of
London ein Lastwagen der britischen
Armee wird bombardiert wobei zwei
Soldaten getötet und Z verwundet werden
während sich die Unruhen auf Zypern
ausweiten beteiligen sich immer mehr
Schüler an der Gewalt hier wird eine
Gruppe von Mädchen nach einer
steinwurfschlacht mit der britischen
Militärpolizei
auseinandergetrieben mit dem Niedergang
des Empire waren die britischen
Handelsinteressen in aller Welt
bedroht im Jahr 1956 verstaatlichte
Ägypten den Sues
Kanal eine neue Krise im Nahen Osten
beginnt als der ägyptische Präsident
nach se einer wildjubelnden Menge in
Alexandria mitteilt dass Ägypten den in
internationalen Besitz befindlichen
Sueskanal beschlagnammt
hat Frankreich und Großbritannien
stellen ein zwstündiges Ultimatum
innerhalb weniger Stunden nach Ablauf
des Ultimatums fliegen britische
Kampfflugzeuge nach Ägypten und greifen
fünf wichtige Städte an darunter
Kairo die Vereinigten Staaten waren
gegen die Invasion und übten Druck auf
Großbritannien und Frankreich aus ihre
Truppen
abzuziehen es wird keine Beteiligung der
Vereinten Staaten an dem
feseligkeiten geben es ist unsere
Hoffnung und Absicht dass diese
Angelegenheit vor die Generalversammlung
der Vereinten Nationen gebracht wird
dort kann die Meinung der Welt in
unserem Streben nach einem gerechten
Ende dieses quälenden Problems zur
Geltung gebracht
werden Großbritannien wurde gedemütigt
die SU Krise bedeutete das Ende seiner
Rolle als eine der größten Mächte der
weltch der k einen Ansturm auf den
Sterling das britische Pfund einige
Leute vermuteten dass die amerikanische
Regierung diesen Ansturm auf das Pfund
förderte als die Finanziers ihr Geld aus
Großbritannien abzogen sank der Wert des
Pfunds um seinen Wert zu schützen
schränkte Großbritannien die
Kreditvergabe der Banken im Ausland
ein sie waren nicht in der Lage im
Ausland zu investieren und
offensichtlich waren sie glcklich wir
kennen den genauen Kontext nicht aber es
ist sehr klar dass die Banken oder ihre
Vertreter bei der Bank of England
vorstellig wurden die ihrerseits von
Vertretern des Bankensektors dominiert
wurde offenbar haben sie die
Vereinbarung getroffen die nie
schriftlich festgehalten wurde dass wenn
Banken zwischen zwei nichtansässigen
vermitteln in einer Fremdwährung in
diesem Fall dem Dollar dass die Bank of
England dieses Geschäft nicht Alster ih
Betten
würde die Banken begannen einen Markt
für Dollar in London zu schaffen den
Londoner eurodollar market um diese
Aktivitäten von ihren innländischen
Bankgeschäften zu unterscheiden führten
die Banken zwei verschiedene
Konten die Bank of England die britische
Aufsichtsbehörde erklärte dass sich die
Londoner euromarket Konten nicht in
London befenden sondern anderswo und
dass sie daher nicht für deren
Regulierung zuständig
sei es geht darum einen legalen Raum zu
schaffen in dem man so tut als würde
eine Aktivität
stattfinden und das wichtigste daran ist
dass man so tut als FE sie nicht in der
Wirtschaft statt in der sie tatsächlich
stattfindet man verlagert also
Aktivitäten von dem Ort an dem sie
reguliert und besteuert werden und tut
so als ob sie anderswo stattfinden
würden wo spielt eigentlich keine Rolle
es ist einfach wo anders als
amerikanische Banken erkannten dass
London die Möglichkeit bot
US-Vorschriften zu umgehen verlagerten
sie ihre internationalen Geschäfte
[Musik]
dorthin etwa zur gleichen Zeit als die
amerikanischen Banken ihre
internationalen Geschäfte nach London
verlegten begann eine andere neue Art
von finanzraum zu entstehen weit weg von
London in Großbritanniens
Überseegebieten den letzten Überresten
des
Empire in den 60er Jahren waren die CEN
Inseln ein totales KFF man erzählt sich
dass es so viele Moskitos in der Luft
gab dass sie sogar Kühe ersticken
konnten das ist eine Legende die man
über die CEN Inseln hört ich weiß nicht
wie wah sie ist aber es war nichts los
Buchhalter und Anwälte aus London kamen
auf die keiman Inseln und andere
britische Gebiete und begannen eine
Reihe von Gesetzen und Vorschriften zur
Wahrung des finanzgeheimnisses aus
arbeiten da das wichtigste
Verkaufsargument dieser Rechtsordnungen
die Geheimhaltung war nannte man sie
geheimhaltungsrechtssysteme was die
ceninseln Taten war schlicht eine
illegale Aktivität da kamen Drogengelder
in riesigen Mengen rein
Steuerhinterziehung was immer man wollte
man konnte es haben die Bank of England
beobachtete die Entwicklungen von London
aus und notierte in einem als geheim
gekennzeichneten Bericht vom 11 April
69 wir müssen ganz sicher sein dass die
mögliche Ausbreitung
vonuhandgesschaften Banken und so we die
in den meisten Fällen nicht mehr als
Messing Schilder wären die
Vermögenswerte außerhalb der Inseln
manipulieren nicht außer Kontrolle gerät
es ist natürlich nichts dagegen
einzuwenden dass sie Schlupflöcher für
Gebietsfremde bieten aber wir müssen
sicher sein dass dadurch keine
Möglichkeit für den Transfer von
britischem Kapital in den nicht Sterling
Raum außerhalb der britischen Regeln
geschaffen werden
[Musik]
diese kleineen Territorien die letzten
Überbleibsel des britischen Empires die
immer noch Überseegebiete sind von
diesen Überseegebieten gibt es 14 sieben
von ihnen sind gutgläubige Steueroasen
einschließlich der CEN Inseln der
Bermudas und der Britischen
Jungferninseln einige der größten
Steueroasen der Welt sind immer noch
britisch mit dem Zugang zu großen Mengen
an offshor Geld wuchs der euromarket
schnell 1980 hatte er 500 Milliarden
Dollar
erreicht
1988 4,8 Billionen Dollar und
1997 wurden fast 90% aller
internationalen Kredite über diesen
Markt
vergeben das britische Empire war
untergegangen und hatte kaum eine Spur
hinterlassen aber die City of Landon
passte sich an und
überlebte
die City of London Londons Finanzviertel
ist ein besonderer
Ort man nannte sie eine Stadt in der
Stadt einen Staat im Staat sie wird von
einer Organisation namens City of London
Corporation verwaltet einem privaten
Unternehmen das alle Funktionen einer
Stadtverwaltung mit einer privaten
Polizei und privaten Gerichten
wahrnimmt diejen unter ihnen die nicht
aus Großbritannien kommen aber die die
es vielleicht sind sie sich nicht
bewusst was für ein seltsames Ding diese
kleine City of London innerhalb des
großen Londons
ist die City of London ist eine vom
größeren London getrennte Einheit und
hat ja eigenes Oberhaupt den Lord Mayer
der sich vom Bürgermeister unterscheidet
der den Rest von London
[Musik]
regiert jedes Jahr im November
veranstaltet die Stadt die Lord Mayers
Show den ältesten bürgerfestzug der
Welt
[Musik]
die City of London hat seit langem einen
merkwürdigen rechtlichen Status denn als
wilhelm der Eroberer 1666 kam war die
Stadt einer der wenigen Teile Englands
die er nicht erobern konnte und schloss
1067 einen Vertrag mit der Stad ab der
erlaubte weiter zu
funktionieren B he
die
Großbritannien gelten ihr politisches
System STT noch aus dem Mittelalter das
gr der Wähler machen nicht die Einwohner
aus sondern die in der Stadt tätigen
Privatunternehmen der Oberbürgermeister
wird von den Oberhäuptern der
mittelalterlichen Zünfte
gewählt sie haben einen vereter im
Unterhaus den abgeseh
vons ähteen im
Unterhaus alle anderen Lobbyisten müssen
in der Lobby anhalten sie dürfen die
Lobby nicht passieren die City of Lon
hat einen ständigen Vertreter im
Unterhaus dessen Aufgabe es ist der City
of Lon Corporation Bericht zu erstatten
und im Namen der Stadt Lobbyarbeit im
Parlament zu
betreibenation of London ist ein
einzigartiges und interessantes Phänomen
D viele Politikwissenschaftler
politische Ökonomen und wir
Wissenschaftler angezogen
hat aber ich kenne niemanden der die
Corporation of London und ihren Einfluss
auf die Politik oder die
Wirtschaftspolitik systematisch
untersucht
hat wir können also nur vermuten dass
die Corporation of London extrem mächtig
und in der Lage ist die britische
Politik auf die eine oder andere Weise
zu gestalten vor allem bei den
finanzmethoden
clley der Premierminister nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg hatte etwas über die
City of landondon Corporation zu
sagen wir haben immer wieder gesehen
dass es in diesem Land eine andere Macht
gibt als die die ihren Sitz in
Westminster hat die City of London ein
passender Begriff für eine Ansammlung
von Finanzinteressen ist in der Lage
sich gegen die Regierung des Landes
durchzusetzen diejenigen die das Geld
kontrollieren können im Inn und Ausland
eine Politik betreiben die im Gegensatz
zu die V Volk beschlossen
wurde im Herzen der City of London steht
die Bank of England die Bank of England
ist nicht nur eine Zentralbank sie ist
auch eine
Finanzaufsichtsbehörde beim Untergang
des Empire nutzte die Bank of England
diese regulierungsbefugnis um die Banken
der Welt nach London zu
holen im Jahr 1972 erteilte die Bank of
England der Bank of credit and
commercial international die ihren
Hauptsitz in London einrichtete eine
Lizenz innerhalb von 10 Jahren wuchs die
BCCI zur siebgrößten Bank der Welt heran
10 Jahre später war sie
Bankrott der stellvertretende Direktor
der CIA Richard sagte heute dass die CIA
die BCCI zur Unterstützung von CIA aktiv
übe genutzt
hat aber BCCI hat nicht nur mit den
Geheimdiensten der Welt
zusammengearbeitet sondern war auch an
umfangreichen Finanzbetrügereien
Geldwäscherei und
Terrorismusfinanzierung
beteiligt die BCCI beging internationale
globale Verbrechen von einem Ausmaß das
einem den Verstand RT die BCI
finanzierte den Terrorismus die Bank of
eng W das sagt der Bericht aber anstatt
sie richtig zu überwachen versuchte sie
den Zusammenbruch der Bank zu
verhindern ich sage ganz direkt dass die
Bank of England genügend Informationen
hatte um BCCI 15 Monate früher zu
schließen als sie es getan hat und
Millionen von Kontoinhabern wurden dabei
geschädigt zahlreiche Whistleblower von
BCCI hatten sich an die Bank of England
gewandt doch die Bank of England
unternahm
nichts
die Bank of England hatte reichlich Zeit
einzugreifen und Nachforschungen
anzustellen aber sie hat es nicht getan
denn die Tradition war und ist auch
heute noch dass man sich Hinweise gibt
und dann mit den Jungs die die anderen
Jungs kontrollieren am Mittagstisch kurz
drüber quatscht und dann würde schon
alles gut
werden Robin l pton der Gouverneur der
Bank of England zum Zeitpunkt des
Zusammenbruchs von BCCI sagte das
derzeitigesicht hat der Gemeinschaft
gute Dienste geleistet wenn wir jedes
Mal eine Bank schließen würden wenn wir
einen Betrugsfall aufdeckten gäbe es
weniger Banken als wir derzeit
haben London war für die Banken ein Ort
an dem sie Geschäfte machen konnten die
anders wo nicht erlaubt waren und an dem
sich die leitenden Bankangestellten
keine Gedanken über die Konsequenzen
ihres Handelns machen mussten dies ist
einer der Gründe warum es heute in
London mehr Banken gibt als an jedem
anderen
Finanzplatz
in Großbritannien kommt niemand ins
Gefängnis Bänker kommen nicht ins
Gefängnis sie sind eine geschützte
Spezies und das ist Teil des offshore
Geschäftsmodells des Vereinigten
Königreichs nämlich zu sagen wir werden
euch beschützen wir bringen euer Geld
hierher wir kümmern uns um Euch wir
stecken euch nicht ins Gefängnis wir
lassen euch tun was ihr
wollt eine sanfte Regulierung war eine
Möglichkeit um Unternehmen nach London
zu locken eine andere war die
geheimhaltunger jren Institutionen der
City of London offshore Niederlassungen
in ehemaligen Außenposten des britischen
Empire zu errichten ihr Ziel war es
offshore Zentren mit strengen
Geheimhaltungsvorschriften zu schaffen
um Kapital aus der ganzen Welt
anzuziehen das schweizerbankgeheimnis
ist das bekannteste sie legen ihr Geld
bei einer Schweizer Bank an und
versprechen es niemandem zu sagen das
ist eine Art der Geheimhaltung aber eine
andere Art der Geheimhaltung die sehr
britisch ist ist die Treuhand und die
Hand ist ein sehr schlüpfriger
komplizierter und hinterhältiger
Mechanismus die Legenden über die
Treuhand stammen aus der Zeit der
Kreuzzüge als die Ritter in fremde
Länder zogen um zu kämpfen und ihr
Vermögen in der Obhut vertrauenswürdiger
Verwalter
ließen was
Treuhandgesellschaften letztendlich tun
ist sie spielen mit dem Konzept des
Eigentums Eigentum ist keine so einfache
Sache der Treugeber in diesem Fall der
Ritter übergibt das Vermögen an jemanden
der heutzutage heuhänder genannt wird
oft ein Anwalt rechtlich gesehen sind
sie von diesen Vermögenswerten getrennt
sie gehören nicht ihnen es gibt eine
Schranke sie können dafür nicht
besteuert werden niemand wird etwas über
ihre Verbindung zu diesen
Vermögenswerten herausfinden in den
britischen offshore Rechtssystemen sind
keine Qualifikationen erforderlich um
Treuhänder zu sein jeder kann einen
Trust gründen und als Treuhänder
fungieren es gibt kein Register keine
stellen die bescheinigen dass eine
Treuhandgesellschaft
[Musik]
wurde die einzigen Personen die von der
Errichtung dieser Vereinbarung wissen
sind der Treuhänder und der Treugeber es
gibt keine Verpflichtung sie zu
registrieren es gibt keine Verpflichtung
zur Finanzberichterstattung für Trusts
sie sind nicht verpflichtet irgendwo
Jahresabschlüsse zu hinterlegen Trust
sind also in jeder Hinsicht unsichtbare
Vereinbarungen der
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler J
Wirtschaftsberater für das
geheimhaltungsrechtssystem von
Jersey wir reden hier nicht über ein
paar Millionen wir sprechen über
Billionen Billionen von Dollar an
Kapital die scheinbar niemandem gehören
weder für Steuerzwecke noch für andere
Zwecke die gehören niemandem alles
Kunstwerke Goldbaren Rennpferde Autos
Immobilien nicht nur finanzielle
Vermögenswerte sondern auch eine ganze
Reihe nichtfinanzieller geh diesen Trust
die niemandem
gehören denken Sie einmal darüber nach
denn wir sprechen hier von 50 Billionen
Dollar an Vermögenswerten die sich
hinter diesem Apparat
verbergen die keimaninseln sind eines
von mehreren britischen übersegebieten
die ein neues Abkommen zum
Informationsaustausch mit Großbritannien
und dem Rest Europas unterzeichnet haben
um Steuerhinterziehung zu bekämpfen die
Länder müssen nun automatisch
Einzelheiten über Bankkonten und deren
Verwendung
wurde letzte Woche zum ersten
Unterzeichner es ist wichtig dass die C
Inseln als erstes übersebiet anerkannt
werden dass ein solches Abkommen mit dem
Vereinigten Königreich unterzeichnet hat
und ich denke dies spiegelt den
konstruktiven Ansatz wieder den die
ceninseln bei der Verwirklichung unseres
gemeinsamen Ziels die
Steuerhinterziehung auszurotten verfolgt
haben die Treuhand ist der Kern des
britischen geheimhaltungsmodells sie
haben kein bankengeheimnis das haben die
Schweizer die Briten sind natürlich nur
zu gerne bereit das bankengeheimnis
abzuschaffen weil sie dann einen
größeren Marktanteil er obern könnten
das ist der Grund warum sie das
tun Trust sind der Grundbaustein des
angelsächsischen Bankgeheimnisses und
sie bilden die Basis auf der komplexe
offshor Strukturen entstehen jedes
geheimhaltungsrechtssystem bietet eine
Reihe von Dienstleistungen an von Trusts
über Briefkastenfirmen bisin zu geheimen
Bankkonten und benannten Direktoren die
Kombination dieser Dienstleistungen in
komplexen Strukturen die sich über
mehrere Rechtssysteme erstrecken
ermöglicht die Schaffung von
geheimhaltungsstrukturen die fast
unmöglich zu durchdringen
sind eine offshore Struktur wird von
einem Treuhandfond überlagert die
Treuhandgesellschaft verwaltet das
Vermögen und kontrolliert es
gewissermaßen darunter besitzt die
Treuhandgesellschaft einige
mantelgesellschaften die jeweils in
einem anderen Rechtssystem angesiedelt
sein können sie könnten also eine
Treuhandgesellschaft in einem Land haben
deren Treuhänder in einem anderen Land
sind deren begünstigte in einem anderen
Land sind die wiederum offshore
Gesellschaften in einem anderen Land
besitzt und jede dieser Gesellschaften
könnte dann Vermögenswerte besitzen sie
könnten ein Bankkonto ein rennpfert eine
Yacht ein Gemälde ein Aktienportfolio
oder was auch immer
besitzen es gibt viele Varianten von
Trusts und offshore geheimnisstrukturen
es gibt offshore Anwälte deren Arbeit
darin besteht immer komplexe und
undurchsichtigere Strukturen zu schaffen
das Ziel dieser Strukturen ist es die
Identität der Eigentümer von offshore
Vermögenswerten zu verbergen und es zu
ermöglichen dass offshore Vermögen
wieder in die globalen Märkte
zurückfließt wenn man sich die Menge an
Geld ansieht die von Steueroasen aus
verwaltet wird sieht man dass es eine
Kurve ist die so verläuft und all die
Gespräche die wir geführt haben mit
anderen wunderbaren Menschen die gegen
Steueroasen kämpfen haben nichts
geändert es ist eine Welt in der man
immer weiter redet und immer weiter
redet ja interessant aber ich werde
weiter tun was ich tun will wir wissen
heute alles denn wir hatten die Panama
papers wir haben sie
gesehen und wir sind nicht in der Lage
darauf zu reagieren weil dieses System
wirklich die wenigen Leute schützt die
davon
profitieren
und das sind prozentual gesehen nur sehr
wenige Menschen aber sie sind
mächtig und ich sehe im Panama Ausschuss
in dem ich sitze das einzige was dies
ändern
könnte wäre ein öffentlich zugängliches
Register des wirtschaftlichen Eigentums
der Trusts und aller möglichen
Unternehmen ganz
einfach
die Panama papers sind zugespielte
Dokumente der offshorekzlei mossack
Fonseca mossack Fonseca ist die
viertgrößte offshor Kanzlei die anderen
neun der zehn größten offshorekanzleien
sind in britischen Überseegebieten
registriert wenn sich Länder in
Großbritannien über die Aktivitäten
beschweren die von seinen offshore
Paradiesen aus betrieben werden
behauptet Großbritannien dass diese Orte
unabhängig sind und dass es nichts tun
kann ich habe immer wieder von Beamten
in Berlin und in Paris und in Washington
und in anderen Ländern gehört dass die
britische Regierung ihnen gesagt hat ja
sie wissen sehr wohl was in Jersey vor
sich geht und sie halten es für sehr
bedauerlich aber sie haben nicht die
Befugnis
einzugreifen nun das ist eine glatte
Lüge sie haben die Befugnis einzugreifen
nur Sie entscheiden es nicht zu
tun Großbritannien spielt diese Art von
Spiel in dem es so tut als ob diese Orte
unabhängig wären wenn es ihnen passt
letzten Endes ernennt Großbritannien den
Gouverneur ernennt viele hochhangige
Leute in diesen Ländern ist für die
Außenbeziehungen und die Verteidigung
verantwortlich und kann auch ein Veto
gegen deren Gesetze einlegen
Großbritannien hat also ein hohes Maß an
Kontrolle im Grunde kontrolliert es
diese Orte und lässt Ihnen nur wenig
politischen
Spielraum während seiner Zeit als
Wirtschaftsberater von Jersey reiste
John chrenson häfig nach London zu
Gesprächen mit verschiedenen britischen
Regierungsstellen als Wirtschaftsberater
hatte ich viel Kontakt mit verschiedenen
Ministerien traditionell haben die
britischen Regierungen versucht sich
nicht in die inneren Angelegenheiten von
Orten wie Jersey einzumischen es
geschieht also auf eine eher subtile Art
und Weise man geht zu jemandem im
Innenministerium oder im
Finanzministerium und er
sagt wir sind eigentlich nicht besonders
scharf auf dieses Gesetz es wäre
vielleicht eine gute Idee wenn Sie
diesen Weg nicht einschlagen würden und
bei einer Tasse Tee ist das ein ziemlich
starkes Signal das Signal geht zurück
auf die Inseln und sagt dass sie nicht
wollen dass ihr das
macht die britische Regierung zieht es
vor sich nicht offen einzumischen
sondern teilt ihre Wünsche durch
informelle Gespräche
mit es gibt keine Papiere oder eine
offizielle Erklärung die Diskussionen
finden hinter verschlossenen Türen
statt zwischen diesen Orten und London
hat viel mit dem britischen
Establishment zu tun und damit dass man
sich gegenseitig
versteht jeder der Brite ist oder die
Briten kennt weiß dass die Kommunikation
zwischen uns oft sehr subtil ist und man
die Codes kennen muss wenn die Leute
etwas sagen es ist viel Ironie im Spiel
und eine Menge kodifizierter
Sprache man muss verstehen wie es
funktioniert
und ich glaube das ist bei den
britischen Beziehungen zu den
Steuerparadiesen sehr stark der Fall ich
glaube es gibt ein großes Verständnis
dafür was wir tun können und was nicht
ohne dass man es wirklich aussprechen
muss indem Großbritannien seine Macht
verborgen hält kann es behaupten dass
diese Länder politisch autonom
sind Unabhängigkeit für die keimaninseln
steht nicht auf der Agenda der Regierung
Botschaft wird an den unsonderausschuss
zur Entkolonialisierung geschickt der
Anwalt Steve mcfield wird die Regierung
bei dem Treffen vertreten das Komitee
soll Kolonien auf der ganzen Welt auf
dem Weg in die Unabhängigkeit begleiten
aber mcfield sagt Kean sei nicht bereit
für diesen
Übergang und die Botschaft ist dass der
Premier dieses Kabinett diese Partei
kein Mandat von der Bevölkerung der
cayen Inseln hat die Unabhängigkeit
anzustreben diese Botschaft werde ich
überbringen als die Bahamas
ih Unabhängigkeit von Großbritannien
erklärten verlegten die offshore ber
ihren Sitz auf die keimaninseln und
setzten von dort aus ihre Geschäfte fort
es war die britische Verbindung die den
bänern und ihren Kunden die Gewissheit
gab dass Ihr Geld sicher
war dieses britische Fundament hat es
diesen Orten ermöglicht das Vertrauen
der
Finanzdienstleistungsbranche und der off
Finanzbranche und dieser Leute
zuwinen in Wirklichkeit wir ein
groteilmög in den offshore Oasen
verwaltet wird von London aus
kontrolliert die City of London erledigt
ihre schmutzige Arbeit im Großen und
Ganzen gerne außerhalb Londons es könnte
Gott bewahre eine Aufsichtsbehörde geben
die die Arbeit ernst nimmt und sie in
London wegen Betrugs verfolgt es ist
also besser die Betrügereien offshore in
Gibraltar oder Jersey zu machen wo das
Risiko einer ernsthaften Strafverfolgung
viel geringer
ist die Geschäfte werden oft in London
besprochen abgeschlossen dann aber aus
steuerlichen und regulatorischen Gründen
im Ausland
registriert sie erlauben es der City in
schmutzige Geschäfte verwickelt zu
werden aber wenn der Skandal zuschlägt
sagen sie also die sind unabhängig wir
können nichts gegen diese Unternehmen
tun das sind nicht wir das sind
Aktivitäten in Steueroasen und wir sind
die Stadt wir haben mit solchen Dingen
nichts zu tun es ist also eine
unglaublich bequeme
Beziehung
die City of London hat die Art und Weise
geprägt wie sich Jersey Gy und die
britischen überseegebieter als
Steueroasen entwickelt haben ich sehe
diese Orte als die Frankensteins die von
der City of London geschaffen
wurden heute ist das Vereinigte
Königreich der weltweit größte Anbieter
von internationalen
Finanzdienstleistungen das Vereinigte
Königreich hat eine fast einzigartige
Rolle im globalen Finanzwesen wenn man
sich die Daten ansieht die Art von Daten
die wir im finanzgeheimnisindex erstellt
haben kann man die relativen Anteile der
einzelnen Länder an der weltweiten
Bereitstellung von
Finanzdienstleistungen für
nichtortsansässig geshen es gibt zwei
große Zentren und alles andere ist im
Vergleich dazu ziemlich
klein die beiden großen Zentren sind die
Vereinigten Staaten mit etwa 19% des
Weltmarktes und das Vereinigte
Königreich und seine offshore
Rechtssysteme die etwa 25% des
Weltmarktes
ausmachen und wenn man dazu noch andere
Rechtssysteme hinzurechnet ehemalige
Kolonien die aber erst kürzlich
unabhängig wurden Hongkong Singapur
vielleicht sogar Dubai bahin und Zypern
dann kommt man auf eine Zahl von fast
40% ich glaube dass diese die Position
Londons auf dem globalen Finanzmarkt
besser
wiedergibt die Soldaten gingen die
Verwalter verließen alle Kolonien aber
sie behielten immer noch ein erhebliches
Maß an Kontrolle über die Finanzströme
aus diesen ehemaligen Teilen des
Imperiums und dem Rest der Welt man
könnte es also als ein zweites Imperium
bezeichnen Großbritanniens zweites
Imperium ein verstecktes Finanzimperium
das ich über weite Teile des
erstreckt zur Zeit des britischen Empire
war die City of Lon das größte globale
Finanzzentrum der
Welt nicht nur die britischen Kolonien
sondern auch unabhängige länderwickelten
ihre Bankgeschäfte in London ab und
nutzten die Währung des Empire für
Handel und
Finanzierung mit dem Niedergang des
Empire ging auch die City of landen
unter die Einrichtung des Londoner EUR
ermöglichte es den Banken der City of
London ihre Netzwerke und ihr Fachwissen
aus der Zeit des Empire weiter zu nutzen
und die Schaffung von
geheimhaltungszonen verschaffte den
Banken Zugang zu großen Mengen billigen
Geldes internationale Banken aus der
ganzen Welt gründeten Niederlassungen in
London und in den britischen offshore
Ländern um von diesem neuen System zu
profitieren dieses System hat den Platz
der Besatzung
eingenommen
in Frankreich war es bis
1962 so in England weiß ich es nicht
aber ungefähr zur gleichen Zeit war
England z.B in Indien oder in anderen
Kolonien physisch präsent und wenn man
sich die Geldströme durch die
Steuerparadiese ansieht dann nehmen Sie
zu wenn wir uns aus den Kolonien
zurückziehen wir plündern als ehemalige
Kolonialmächte immer noch die
Entwicklungsländer
wohlhabende Einzelpersonen das
organisierte Verbrechen und Unternehmen
verlagerten ihren Reichtum ins Ausland
im Austausch für Geheimhaltung und
Steuerfreiheit und als Länder aus der
ganzen Welt begannen ihre
Volkswirtschaften zu deregulieren und zu
öffnen wurde es immer einfacher dies zu
tun heute könnte die Hälfte des
weltweiten offshore Vermögens in
Großbritanniens geheimen Rechtssystemen
versteckt
sein einer der Verlierer ist Afrika
dessen fluchtkapital hauptsächlich in
das moderne britische Spinnennetz
fließt ich glaube es ist kein Zufall
dass Großbritanniens offshore Imperium
mehr oder weniger zur gleichen Zeit
entstand wieer Zusammenbruch des
formellen
Imperiums wir neigen dazu uns Afrika als
einen riesigen nettoschuldner gegenüber
dem Rest der Welt vorzustellen aber das
hier war das Ausmaß ihrer Schulden Ende
die Schulden der afrikanischen Länder
südlich der Sahara beliefen sich 2008
auf 177 Milliarden Dollar doch der
Reichtum den die Eliten dieser Länder
zwischen 1970 und 2008 ins Ausland
verschoben wird auf
944 Milliarden Dollar geschätzt mehr als
das
fünache944 Milliarden doll Renen sie
nachka ein nettchuldner zu sein Afrika
südlich der Sahara ist ein
nettogläubiger für den Rest der
Welt als das Kapital ins Ausland
abwanderte lien sich die afrikanischen
Staaten Geld von internationalen Banken
zu hohen Zinsen mit der Zeit wurden
diese Schulden so hoch dass sie
möglicherweise nie zurückgezahlt werden
können die geheime Rechtssprechung
brachte die Entwicklungsländer um ihren
Reichtum und ihre
Steuereinnahmen Suen viele
Entwicklungsländer darunter seit kurzem
auch Ecuador ein un steuergremium
einzurichten das einen höheren Standard
hat als das derzeitige un-steuergremium
und jedes Mal wenn das passierte wurde
es blockiert während des Prozesses der
Entwicklungsfinanzierung in ades Abeba
im letzten Jahr waren es glaube ich das
Vereinigte Königreich und die USA die
erneut Versuche zur Einrichtung dieser
weltsteuerorganisation blockierten warum
wollen Sie keine demokratische
Entscheidungsfindung bei globalen
Entscheidungen darüber wie Steuern
grenzüberschreitend erhoben werden ich
verstehe das nicht solange wir
grenzüberschreitende Aktivitäten haben
die sowohl kriminelle als auch legale
Aktivitäten beinhalten solange wir nicht
in der Lage sind diese beiden zu trennen
wird dies weiterhin ein Problem
sein die westlichen Länder blockieren
Versuche für mehr Transparenz bei den
internationalen Finanzströmen zu sorgen
und globale Standards für die
grenzüberschreitende Steuererhebung
einzuführen während die in den
Entwicklungsländern offshore Zentren
nutzen um ihren Reichtum im Ausland zu
verstecken das Öl in Gabun ist den
Menschen in Gabun nicht zugute gekommen
das gilt auch für das Kupfer in Sambia
und für das Gold in Mosambik oder in
Mali die Unternehmen die es fördern und
ihre Aktionäre haben davon profitiert
die korrupte Elite des Landes hat davon
profitiert
in den Entwicklungsländern hat das offsh
System der Steuerparadiese die
Ausplünderung dieser Länder durch ihre
Eliten erleichtert es hat ihnen
ermöglicht das Geld zu stehlen und es
irgendwo anders sicher
aufzubewahren unerlaubte Finanzströme
weil die Anonymität die ihnen zugrunde
liegt Anreize für Menschen in
Machtpositionen schafft korrupt zu sein
das ist der Grund warum es eine Gruppe
von Ländern gibt in denen entwilungs
Schritte so schwierig sind das liegt
daran dass die Anreize für
Einzelpersonen und die Möglichkeiten sie
durch all die Mechanismen zu verfolgen
die illegalen Finanzströmen zugrunde
liegen schwerer wiegen als die Art von
Mechanismen die zu einem mächtigen
repräsentativen effektiven Staat führen
der die Entwicklung in Gang bringen
kann verlieren die Entwicklungsländer
jedes Jahr über eine Billion Dollar
durch Kapitalflucht und
Steuerhinterziehung der größte Teil
dieses Reichtums fließt in große
westliche Länder wie die Vereinigten
Staaten und Großbritannien und
ermöglicht es deren Währungen stark zu
bleiben während die Währungen der
Entwicklungsländer schwach bleiben aber
die illegalen Ströme in die westlichen
Länder hatten noch einen weiteren
unerwarteten Nebeneffekt in den
Volkswirtschaften der Vereinigten
Staaten und Großbritanniens begann eine
Finanzialisierung die Ursprünge dieses
Finanzmarktkapitalismus oder der
Deindustrialisierung reichen bis in die
60er Jahre zurück
antikriegsdemonstranten protestieren
gegen die Beteiligung der USA am
Vietnamkrieg in massenmärischen
kunundtgebungen und Demonstrationen
Präsident Johnson ließ verlauten dass
das FBI alle antikriegsaktivitäten genau
beobachtet in den 60er Jahren arbeitete
der US Wirtschaftswissenschaftler
Michael Hudson bei der Chase Manhattan
Bank an der
EXP die
zahlsbanz in den 60er Jahren war das
zahlungsbilanzdefizit der Vereinigten
Staaten ausschließlich auf ausländische
Militärausgaben
zurückzuführen aufgrund der Kosten des
Vietnamkrieges flossen Dollars aus den
Vereinigten Staaten ab die USA
versuchten zu verhindern dass die
Dollars die nach Vietnam flossen auf
ausländischen Banken deponiert
wurden die Regierung ch während des
Vietnamkrieg eine Filiale inon
einzurichten wie Sie sich vorstellen
können gab es dort keine Fenster es war
eine Art Festung und sie verlor Geld
aber die Regierung ging zu Chase und
sagte wenn Sie dieses Geld das vom
Militär in Vietnam abgeworfen wird nicht
kriegen dann wird es in französische
Banken fließen es wird zu general de Gul
gelangen und sie wissen was er dann
damit tun wird er wird es gegen Gold
eintauschen das ist das was die USA zu
verhindern
versuchten da es den USA nicht gelang
den Geldabfluss zu stoppen begannen sie
einen anderen Plan auszuhcken
1967 bekam Michael Hudson von einem
ehemaligen Mitarbeiter des
Außenministeriums ein Memo in die Hand
gedrückt 1967 gab mir ein ehemaliger
Mitarbeiter des Außenministeriums im
Aufzug von Chase Manhattan ein Memo ind
dem darauf gedrängt wurde dass Chase
Manhattan die Führung dabei übernehmen
solle den Vereinigten Staaten dabei zu
helfen die Schweiz der Welt zu
werden das heißt die Schweiz für
fluchtkapital das Außenministerium
forderte mich auf zu schätzen wie viel
Geld meiner Meinung nach zur Verfügung
steht wenn Amerika die neue Schweiz
werden würde und wie wir das anstellen
könnten der Plan war offshore
bankzentren in der Karibik und anderswur
zu organisieren und dass das heiße Geld
nicht direkt zu Chase kommen würde weil
das nicht schön und legal
wäre was passierte war dass die
lateinamerikanischen Kriminellen und
andere kriminelle Drogenhändler alle
Arten des organisierten Verbrechens ihr
Geld in die offshorebanken in der
Karibik steckten und diese
offshorebanken würden dann den Zufluss
in der Zentrale
einzahlen indem sie offshore Dollars
zurück in die Vereinigten Staaten
transferierten konnten die USA den
Abfluss von Dollars stoppen und den Wert
ihrer Währung
Stützen jedes Land achtet auf seinen
Devisenkurs der Wechselkurs bezieht sich
nicht nur auf Importe und Exporte
sondern auch auf Kapitalbewegungen undn
wenn man sich die monatlichen
internationalen finanzstatistiken des
Internationalen Währungsfonds anschaut
hat man eine Art stetige Handelsbilanz
eine stetige Einwanderung und
Überweisungen und was nach oben und
unten geht nennt man Fehler und Lücken
was die Vereinten Nationen und der IWF
als Fehler und Lücken bezeichnen ist
fluchtkapital der Grund für diese Lücken
ist dass sie sich damit nicht wirklich
befassen
wollen in den 30er Jahren wollte Roy h
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler im usels
Ministerium kriminelle Bewegungen in die
zahlungsbilanzstatistik
aufnehmen der Kongress war sehr
verärgert man sagte mir in Washington
das Argument sei wir sind ein
christliches Land wir wollen keine
Verbrechen
melden man verbot ihm kriminelles Geld
in die Zahlungsbilanz aufzunehmen ich
glaube heute nennt man das Fehler und
Lücken man nennt es nicht mehr
Kriminelle zu und
abüsse
in den 60er und 70er Jahren stand
Großbritannien vor einem ähnlichen
Dilemma wie die Vereinigten Staaten das
Geld floss ab und dadurch sank der Wert
des Pfunds Großbritannien erkannte dass
es den Wert seiner Währung stützen
konnte indem es seinen Inlandsmarkt für
die Billionen von Dollars öffnete die
durch seine offshore Häfen flossen aber
genau wie in den Vereinigten Staten
hatte dies einen unerwarteten
Nebeneffekt
britische Banken stecken heute genau wie
im 19 Jahrhundert ihr Geld nicht in die
britische Produktion sondern in
Immobilienspekulationen in
Finanzspekulationen und in den
Devisenhandel die Finanzialisierung
Londons hat also zur
Deindustrialisierung des Landes
beigetragen denn sie hat es ermöglicht
dass der Sterling durch diesen riesigen
Zustrom von heißem Geld gestützt wird
diesen Zustrom von Geld aus dem
Drogenhandel von kriminellem Geld und
Geld aus der Steuerhinterziehung in der
ganzen Welt das nach London fließt
anstatt in die Schweiz nach
lichttenstein oder in die
karibek mit der stillschweigenden
Unterstützung der Vereinigten Staaten
wuchsen die britischen offshoreoasen
rasch an und schon bald entwickelte sich
das offshystem zum dominierenden
internationalen Finanzmarkt der Welt nur
wenige wussten wie dieser Markt
funktionierte 1986 ging der
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler
Ausland um dies zu untersuchen er bewarb
sich um eine Stelle in der Niederlassung
einer der größten
Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaften der
Welt in Jersey be habe ich in der
sogenannten Unternehmens und
Treuhandverwaltung gearbeitet also im
Bereich offsh ich bin extra ins Ausland
gegangen um in diesem Bereich zu
arbeiten weil man dort mit den offshore
Gesellschaften den mantelgesellschaften
und den offshore Trust zu tun hat und
sie verwaltet auf diese Weise konnte ich
von der Arbeit in einer großen globalen
wirtschas Prüfungsgesellschaft aus genau
sehen was die Kunden
Taten ich hatte vollständigen Zugang zu
allen kundenakten und im Laufe meiner
Arbeit bei die Leuten Touch habe ich
über 100 ihrer offshore Kunden
untersucht und das habe ich gefunden es
gab einige insiderhändler einige
Marktmanipulationen einige die die
Offenlegung von Interessenkonflikten
vermieden illegalen Waffenhandel
illegale politische
Wahlkampfspenden Schmiergelder
Bestechung betrügerische
Rechnungstellung falsche Preisgestaltung
im Handel und
Steuerhinterziehung das ist was die
Kunden getan
[Musik]
haben auf der Grundlage einer Stichprobe
der Kunden die ich mir angesehen habe
war kein einziger Kunde in etwas
verwickelt was ich als wirklich legitime
Aktivität ansehen würde sie waren alle
in irgendeiner Art von
Steuerhinterziehung oder Schlimmeres
verwickelt
ich habe mich mit Carl leen getroffen er
war früher ein amerikanischer Senator
und er hat sich eingehend über das
Private Banking
erkundigt er fragte die Banker was
glauben Sie wie hoch ist der Prozentsatz
der Kunden die diese Unternehmen für
legitime Zwecke
nutzen und die Antwort lautete ich
glaube dass
9,9% meiner Kunden diese Unternehmen für
illegale Zwecke
nutzen
das ist die Realität das sind
amerikanische Banker die erzählen was
sie tun und genau dasselbe gilt für
britische Bänker die ihren Kunden helfen
konnten in Panama oder auf den Bermudas
oder den britischen keimaninseln zu
haben
geheimhaltungsrechtssprechung wird in
Hoh Maße für betrügerische
Finanzaktivitäten und Grauzonen genutzt
Bereiche in denen die nicht nur
wünschenswert sondern eine Notwendigkeit
ist legitime Finanzaktivitäten brauchen
weder die Geheimhaltung die offshore
Oasen bieten noch wollen sie die hohen
Gebühren zahlen die offshore Banken und
Anwaltskanzleien
verlangen heute sind fast die Hälfte der
geheimen Gerichtsbarkeiten der Welt
britische
Dependenzen in der Öffentlichkeit
behaupten diese Länder sie seien
transparent und ihre
finanzdienstleistungek
Finanzaktivitäten
beschäftigt unsere Wirtschaft basiert
nicht auf Geheimhaltung sie basiert auf
Transparenz sie basiert auf einem
soliden regulatorischen Umfeld sie
basiert auf guter Regierungsführung und
guter Regierung mit einem Rechtssystem
der britischen
Regierung darauf basieren unsere
Finanzinstitute wir haben nun eine
Anwort von
deranzeh Gruppe von us-aktivisten
angekündigt hat herzukommen um auf die
ihrer Meinung nach bestehende
Steuerhinterziehung von Unternehmen
aufmerksam zu machen der Vorsitzende des
Finanzministeriums Richard Cole ermutigt
die Gruppe zu einem Besuch und sagt der
Sektor habe nichts zu
verbergen ich würde sagen wenn jemand
nach cman kommen will um herauszufinden
was wir hier tun dann soll er kommen wir
haben hier keine
Geheimnisse als ich 2008 auf die C
Inseln kam R ich den Regierungssprecher
an und er sagte wir haben eine Anweisung
von ganz oben dass niemand mit ihnen
sprechen darf sie sind
tabu im Jahr 2011 veröffentlichte der
Journalist nicolason treasure Islands
ein bahnbrechendes Buch über das offsh
System der Autor internationaler
Medienberichte sagt er würde sich über
ein Gespräch mit dem Vorsitzenden der
Con finance Tony TRAV
fre kzlich einen Schwachkopf mit dem
verstnis eines
es wird immer eine Politik des Neides
geben jetzt wird die Politik des Neides
durch Schwachköpfe verschärft die nicht
wirklich verstehen was auf den CEN
Inseln vor sich geht ich weiß nicht
wovon er redet und er weiß auch nicht
wovon er
redet die keimaninseln sind der
fünfgrößte Finanzplatz der Welt sie
beherbergen 80 000 registrierte
Unternehmen mehr als Dreiviertel der
weltweiten hgefond und 1,9 Billionen
Dollar an Einlagen die Einwohnerzahl
beträgt 60.000 was in etwa der Zahl der
Obdachlosen in New York
entspricht die offshorwt wird von einer
seltsamen Mischung von Charakteren
bevölkert britische
Exschüler Mitglieder der Geheimdienste
der Welt globale kriminelle verschiedene
Herren und Damen und Bänker in Hülle und
Fülle
dafür so viele reiche und mächtige
Personen so viel auf dem Spiel steht ist
es nicht verwunderlich dass
Großbritanniens offshore Häfen ihre
eigenen seltsamen Mechanismen entwickelt
haben um zu verhindern dass
Informationen nach außen
dringen für viele Menschen die im
Ausland arbeiten und denen nicht gefällt
was sie tun ist es in der Tat sehr
schwer eine andere Meinung zu vertreten
denn sie werden persönlich mit einem
Grad an Bösartigkeit angegriffen der
ziemlich außergewöhnlich ist meistens
sind die Instrumente der Unterdrückung
relativ raffiniert du wirst nicht
befördert wenn du das tust deine Familie
wird es nicht
mögen es geht nicht darum sie ins
Gefängnis zu stecken das ist viel zu
plump wir reden hier über das
Establishment in diesen Fällen das
britische Establishment und die
Mechanismen sind sehr sehr subtil eine
Art von chtung z.B
diese seltsamen Mechanismen wenn jemand
versucht die Sache zu verraten da gibt
es alle möglichen Methoden man feuert
sie nicht einfach man gibt ihnen viel zu
viel Arbeit man lenkt sie in eine andere
Richtung jemand der sehr gut weiß wie
Unterdrückung im Ausland funktioniert
ist der ehemalige Gesundheitsminister
von Jersey
Start 2009 ließ er einen Bericht über
eine Krankenschwester durchsickern die
verdächtigt wurde Patienten bracht zu
haben am 10 März spitzte sich die
Angelegenheit während einer
Parlamentsdebatte zu Senator behauptete
Senator Jimmy pasard habe ihn beschimpft
und gesagt er solle sich selbst Köpfen
gehen perard wies die Behauptung zurück
aber weniger als eine Woche später
musste er zugeben dass er gelogen hatte
er räumte ein dass er Senator bei
anderer Gelegenheit gesagt habe er SLE
sich die Pulsadern aufschneiden und
damit allen einen Gefallen
tun ich wurde eines Morgens in meinem
Haus von sechs Polizeibeamten in Zivil
verhaftet da waren noch zwei
Spezialisten Polizeibeamte für die
Datensuche und zwei weitere
Polizeibeamte in ganzkörperpanzerung mit
einem dieser ramböcke die sie bei
drogenratien
Einsetzen Zeh Polizisten stürmten also
ohne Durchsuchungsbefehl auf mich zu die
Wohnung wurde von oben bis unten
durchsucht alle Computer Beschlag und
alle möglichen privaten
wahlkreisdaten kurz nachdem wir mit den
Dreharbeiten begonnen hatten verließ ein
Polizeibeamter das Revier im
Vorbeilaufen grinste er in die
Kamera der Beamte wollte die Sirenen an
seinem Motorrad testen was er während
des restlichen Interviews in
regelmäßigen Abständen
Tat als es darum ging mich zu
belangen wurde nach dem
Datenschutzgesetz
belangt als die Behörden mich
strafrechtlich verfolgten sagte ich die
sei eine legitime Verteidigung im
öffentlichen Interesse zusammen mit
einem Sachverständigen legte ich eine
Reihe von Berichten vor die den Fall der
Staatsanwaltschaft effektiv
[Musik]
zerstörten als Reaktion darauf
entschieden die Richter dass
verteidigungssache er habe den Bericht
im öffentlichen Interesse weitergegeben
nicht mehr zulässig
sei trotzdem verfol
ohne eine Verteidigung in den
vergangenen 7 Jahren wurde wiederholt
vor Gericht gestellt und dreimal
inhaftiert er weiß nicht ob und wann die
Verfolgung enden wird und er weiß auch
nicht wann er wieder hinter Gittern
landen
wird wenn man J von außen betrachtet
sieht g es ein strafverfolgssystem ein
Gericht und eine
legis D ist real es ist ein potemkinches
Dorf eines dieser Systeme in Jersey
erfüllt die Anforderung objektiv zu
sein objektiv zu sein oder tatsächlich
richtig zu
funktionieren die Erfahrung die ST
gemacht hat liegt vielleicht am unteren
Ende der Skala er wurde einfach
unterdrückt und wegen erfundener
Anschuldigungen vor Gericht
[Musik]
gestellt
lassen Sie uns das Interview fortsetzen
vielleicht langweilen die sich
irgendwann so läuft die Unterdrückung in
Jersey es werden alle möglichen kleinen
Dinge getan um Leute zu schikanieren sie
gehen nicht oft zu solchen extremen über
wie sie es gegen mich getan haben indem
sie mich tatsächlich verhaften und ins
Gefängnis stecken die Behörden wenden
alle möglichen anderen Methoden an um
Leute zu behindindern Dinge zu
sabotieren und den Leuten das Leben wer
zu wenn du das Establishment in jersy
verärgerst wirst du hier keinen Job
bekommen deine Kinder werden keine
anständigen Jobs bekommen so ungefähr
funktioniert
das ich war im März 2009 mit Nick Jason
in Jersey etwa 24 Stunden nach unserer
Ankunft in Jersey wir waren mehrere Tage
dort sagteck hastemkt wir
verfolgerden en angekommen sind werden
wir verfolgt schau jetzt nicht hin aber
wir werden
verfolgt es stellte sich heraus dass er
Recht hatte wir wurden verfolgt und das
fand ich beunruhigend sehr beunruhigend
sogar es gibt ein Sprichwort in Jersey
wenn es dir hier nicht gefällt gibt es
morgens immer ein
Boot in der Werbebroschüre von Jersey
finance heißt es Jersey ist eine
Erweiterung der City of
London das ist der Ort an dem die City
of London viele der Aktivitäten
durchführt die sie in London selbst
nicht durchführen
könnte wir sind hier um über diese Firma
namens applebe zu sprechen ich werde
einfach vorlesen was Sie auf Ihrer
Webseite sagen Mitarbeiter von applebe
haben es nicht nur in politische Ämter
geschafft sondern in Zentren wie den
Bermudas Jersey der e of Man und den
keimaninseln in hohe richterliche Ämter
sie rühmen sich also damit es Ihre
Mitarbeiter einen Austausch mit den
Leuten haben die in diesen offshore
Finanzzentren an der Macht
sind dieselben Anwälte und Buchhalter
die offshore Trusts einrichten und
verwalten sind auch in hohen politischen
Positionen tätig in Großbritanniens
offshorwelt sind die meisten Politiker
in der Wirtschaft tätig sie betreiben
Lobbyarbeit für die Wirtschaft und
fördern deren Interessen sie entwerfen
verinern und verabschieden Gesetze
Politiker sitzen in den Vorständen der
Unternehmen die sie eigentlich
regulieren
sollen es gibt keinen Platz für
schmutziges Geld in
Großbritannien in der Tat sollte es
nirgendwo einen Platz für schmutziges
Geld geben die Herausforderung die ich
heute an jedes Land Stelle besteht darin
die Korruption auszurotten Transparenz
darüber zu gewährleisten was ihre
eigenen Unternehmen tun und Transparenz
auch für ausländische Unternehmen in
ihrem Land zu verlangen und mit uns
zusammenzuarbeiten um diesen Ansatz der
Transparenz auf der ganzen Welt zu
verbreiten in der Öffentlichkeit
behaupten britische Politiker sie würden
gegen Geheimhaltungsvorschriften und
Korruption vorgehen aber in der Praxis
tun sie das
Gegenteil wenn ich mit Politikern in
Brüssel spreche sagen sie dass mehr
Lobbyisten aus London auch Politiker zu
ihnen gekommen sind um die Interessen
der City of London zu schützen als aus
allen anderen europäischen
Mitgliedsstaaten zusammen das gibt Ihnen
eine Vorstellung davon in welchem Ausmaß
britische Politiker sich im Wesentlichen
als Lobbyisten für die City of London
sehen wir beginnen mit unserer großen
Geschichte die Bemühungen der
keimaninseln um Transparenz im
Finanzdienstleistungssektor werden von
der internationalen Gemeinschaft
anerkannt der britische Premierminister
Cameron erklärte dem Parlament das
Etikett Steueroase das in
kronbesitzungen und Überseegebieten
angeheftet wird sei
unfair viele britische Politiker haben
persönliche und geschäftliche
Verbindungen zur City of landen und zu
britischen
Steueroasen der Vater des ehemaligen
britischen Premierministers David
Cameron Ian Cameron war ein Experte für
Offshore Fonds und war seit den 80er
Jahren an offshore Trusts
beteiligt in diesem Gerichtsgebäude hier
in St hia haben wir dies gefunden es ist
ein Dokument das sich
testamentsvollstckerzeugnis nennt und
zum Testament von niemand anderem als
Ian Cameron gehört David Camerons
[Applaus]
Vater Ian Cameron war sicherlich ein
wohlhabender Mann 2009 wurde sein
persönliches Vermögen in der Sunday
Times rich List auf 10 Millionen Pfund
geschätzt doch als er 2010 starb war
sein Nachlass viel kleiner als erwartet
nämlich nur 2,7 Millionen
pund
in vielen Fällen sind es die Politiker
und ihre Busenfreunde Familien und so
weiter und die Geschäftsleute die die
Parteien sponsorn die diese offshore
Dienste nutzen sie haben also kein
persönliches Interesse daran sie zu
schließen wenn Sie das tun wollten
könnten sie es morgen tun tatsache ist
dass sie es nicht wollen weil sie selbst
darin verwickelt
sind wenn man aus dem gleichen milie
kommt und die richtigen Leute kennten
alle chen feinheitent Weg man kann alle
möglichen Dinge tun die man nicht
einfach so tun würde wenn man an die Tür
klopft und fragt ob man eine Offshore
Firma gründen kann um dies zu tun wird
man zum Teufel gejagt aber wenn man Teil
des Netzwerks ist kann man solche Dinge
tun das ist ein sehr wichtiger Teil des
ganzen Systems dieses britische
Establishment der Oberschicht das es
schon seit Jahrhunderten
gibt das
britischees privilegierter Eliten hatte
sich nach dem Untergang des Empire eine
lukrative Nische in der offshorwt
geschaffen sie wandelten sich von
Verwaltern des
Empire zu finanzverwaltern für die
globale Elite und multinationale
Konzerne je mehr Geld ins Ausland floss
desto mehr bekamen die Gesellschaften
rund um den Globus die Auswirkungen der
offshorewt zu
spüren in Wirklichkeit ist es nicht so
wie Sie denken dass ihr Premierminister
die Macht hat über die Zukunft ihres
Landes zu
entscheiden die Macht ist hier
versteckt es gibt immer mehr Länder auf
der Welt in denen der Mangel an
finanzieller Transparenz bei der
Besteuerung bei den
Eigentumsverhältnissen und bei der
Korruption das Ausmaß untergräbt indem
die Regierungen repräsentative
politische Entscheidungen für ihre
Bürger treffen wir haben Extremfälle wie
die versteckte Steuerhinterziehung durch
Leute in den Finanzministerien in
Griechenland in Frankreich aber wir
haben auch dieses System das im
Allgemeinen auf anonymen Firmenbesitz
ausgerichtet ist den anonymen Besitz von
Immobilien in ganz London in halb
Schottland glauben wir wirklich dass
Regierungen besser funktionieren dass
die Märkte besser funktionieren dass die
Verteilung von Einkommen und Vermögen
besser ist wenn wir zulassen dass so
viel verborgen
bleibt wer will denn nicht wissen mit
wem man Geschäfte macht wer möchte dass
seine Regierung von Leuten geführt wird
deren Vermögen versteckt ist deren
Finanztransaktionen anonym im Ausland
abgewickelt
werden das ist eine schlechte Richtung
für die
Welt die Bürger müssen verstehen was
passiert dass sie die Last tragen und
dass sich einige mächtige Personen von
der Steuerpflicht
befreien die einfachen Leute zahlen
Steuern die Reichen
nicht das ist Ungleichheit und führt zu
Populismus denn es zeigt so deutlich
dass die Menschen die heute an der
Spitze der Welt stehen nicht in der Lage
sind sich um die Interessen der
einfachen Leute zu
kümmern
damals in den 60er und 70er Jahren wurde
Steuerhinterziehung oder der Widerstand
gegen die Besteuerung als etwas
angesehen das gegen das Establishment
gerichtet war sie wissen schon die
Rolling Stones und PH Collins all diese
Leute die ins Ausland abwandern
verschwinden das wurde als eine Art
Rebellion angesehen und wenn man in die
heutige Zeit vorspult dann ist das jetzt
das Establishment das
off ist heute die Art und Weise wie
Eliten und multinationale Konzerne ihre
Geschäfte abwickeln steuerhinterziehung
ist die Art und Weise wie Geschäfte
gemacht
werden diese Art von raffiniertem betrug
erfordert eine riesige Infrastruktur wir
sprechen gerne von der
nadelstreifeninrastruktur hochgebildeter
Menschen die meinen es sei ihr Recht
anderen zu helfen die Gesellschaft zu
betrügen
wir haben eine neue Mafia in der Stadt
sie schießt nicht wirklich auf Menschen
sie schießt ihnen keine Kugeln in die
Kniescheiben aber ihr Handel ist genauso
tödlich sie beraubt die Menschen der
Möglichkeit
Gesundheitsversorgung Bildung Sicherheit
Gerechtigkeit und im Grunde ein
erfülltes Leben zu haben buchalter
bilden das Rückgrad des offystems sie
verwalten die Strukturen die es
einzelpersen
ermöglich ihr Geld ins Ausland zu
verschieben und Steuern zu
hinterziehen es gibt etwa 2,5 Millionen
professionell qualifizierte Buchhalter
auf diesem Planeten etwa 330 000 davon
in
Großbritannien bekannte Leute gut
gekleidet gut gefüttert hochbezahlt
sitzen in ihren Büros im Stadtzentrum
und werden dafür bezahlt sich
steuervermeidungsprogramme für
Privatleute und Unternehmen
auszudenken alle eine Regierung wählen
die sagt wählt uns wir geben euch eine
bessere Gesundheitsversorgung Bildung
und Sicherheit und am nächsten Tag sagt
der Buchhalter tut mir leid leute ihr
habt diese Regierung gewählt aber wir
haben ein steuervermeidungsprogramm und
die Amazons und Googles und Microsoft
werden hier keine Steuern zahlen schade
ihr habt dafür gestimmt aber ihr bekommt
etwas
anderes es ist eine verrückte Welt D ein
Teil des Geschäftsmodells der großen
wirtschaftsprüfungsfirmen darin besteht
Öffentlichkeit Dienstleistungen zu
verweigern indem man die Steuereinnahmen
aushüllt und diese Firmen werden dann
mit staatlich finanzierten Verträgen
belohnt und dieselben Firmen beraten
dann die Regierungen und dieselben
Firmen berichten dann über die
unternehmensabschlüsse und sagen uns
dass alles gut
ist als ich mit einem Partner von Price
waterha darüber sprach sagte er
Professor sie sollten das mehr
anerkennen wir erwirtschaften Millionen
Dollar an Einnahmen und wir haben viele
viele zufriedene Kunden was ist ihr
Problem und meine Antwort war ganz
einfach das ist die Sprache von
Drogenhändlern und
[Musik]
Zuhältern in Großbritannien stieg eine
neue Art von Beamten an die Spitze
auf einer dieser Beamten
war der an die Spitze
der britischen Steuerbehörde
Aufstieg da harnet hatte eine neue Art
der
Steuererhebung Geschäfte wurden auf
individueller Basis und hinter
verschlossenen Türen
ausgehandelt bei den größten Kunden
führte hartnet die Verhandlungen häufig
selbst British Telekom war eines der
ersten Unternehmen das das Programm
durchlief und eine Rückerstattung von
über einer Milliarde pund erhielt der
Vorstand zende von BT benen schrieb der
Gewinn pro Aktie ist um 14% gestiegen
und es ist schön zu wissen dass wir eine
Gutschrift von einer Milliarde Pfund vom
Finanzamt erhalten haben Dave hartnet
behauptete dieser Ansatz sei
effizienter Rechtsstreitigkeiten vor den
Gerichten sind in der heutigen Zeit
überall auf der Welt wirklich phänomenal
teuer und ich denke man sollte sie nach
Möglichkeit vermeiden die Kunst besteht
darin die Leute durch starke Argumente
und ähnliches zur Zahlung zu bewegen
nach dem Ausbruch der Proteste im Jahr
2011 befragte ein Sonderausschuss des
Finanzministeriums dvenet harnet
behauptete er könne aufgrund des
Steuerzahler Geheimnisses keine Auskunft
geben welche gesetzlichen Bestimmungen
hindern sie daran dem Parlament
Informationen zu
geben alles was ich bisher gesagt habe
Herr bar war dass ich und meine Kollegen
durch das Gesetz und die Entscheidung
der Kommissare daran gehindert
werden was Dave harnet nicht erwähnte
die Rechtsberatung die er erhalten hatte
besagt dass die Offenlegung von
Informationen im Ermessen des Chefs des
hmrc liegt der Chef des hmrc war dan
selbst so wie die Mafia in den Staat
eingedrungen ist sind die wirs
Gesellschaften in den Staat eingedrungen
der Leiter der Abteilung für
Steuervermeidung in der britischen
Steuerbehörde kommt aus einer dieser
Firmen der neuernannte Vorsitzende von
Her Majesty revenue and customs einer
Steuerbehörde ist ein Partner von KPMG
ihre Partner sind in den Staat
eingedrungen sie leiten das
Finanzministerium die britische
finanzleistungsindustrie war in den
Staat eingedrungen und begann die
Gesetze zu ihrem eigenen Vorteil zu
gestalten
das Ausmaß der politischen Vereinnahmung
durch die City of London durch die
großen Banken und die großen
Anwaltskanzleien ist so enorm dass die
Politiker praktisch zu deren sprachhoren
geworden
sind da die Regierung nicht bereit ist
im Interesse der Öffentlichkeit zu
handeln konfrontierte eine Gruppe von
Demonstranten Dave hartnet bei einer
privaten Veranstaltung in
Oxford es tut uns leid sie zu stören wir
werden nur ein paar Augenblicke ihrer
Zeit in Anspruch nehmen wir sind heute
Abend hier um Dave eine Auszeichnung zu
überreichen den Preis für sein
Lebenswerk für seine Verdienste um die
Steuerplanung von
[Applaus]
Unternehmen dave ist ein großartiger
Freund der Branche ein großartiger
Freund für viele von uns im Laufe der
Jahre wir können dir wirklich nicht
genug danken für das was du getan
hast haben dadurch Milliarden an Steuern
gespart und auch unsere Freunde bei
Goldman haben dadurch Millionen gespart
Millionen diese Leute sind
Eindringlinge dies ist eine
ungesetzliche Verschwörung zum
Hausfriedensbruch und sie werden gehen
Sir sie werden sofort gehen bevor wir
die Hunde auf sie
hetzen
gehen Sie das ist Hausfriedensbruch
abschau gehen
sie nach seiner Pensionierung wechselte
in die Privatwirtschaft unter anderem
ügellschaft wo er ausländische
Regierungen in Sachen
Unternehmensbesteuerung
berät da harnet ist Mitglied eines
britischen Ritterordens eine
Auszeichnung die ihm von der britischen
Monarchin verliehen
wurde es gibt ehemalige Minister die als
Berater für
Wirtschaftsprüfungsunternehmen tätig
sind
wirtschaftsprüfungsunternehmeneten
poellen Ministern Arbeits und
Beratungsdienste an meiner Meinung nach
ist das ein Hinweis auf korrupte
Strukturen man kauft und verkauft
Einfluss wenn ein ehemaliger Minister
für eine
Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaft arbeitet
vermittelt er kein buchhaltungswissen er
eröffnet politische Möglichkeiten im In
und Ausland das ist das was sie
tun ich hoffe dass sie es inzwischen
sehen wie ich ich traue den meisten
Bankern nicht den meisten Anwälten und
Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaften ich
glaube dass sie sich in einer
Verschwörung gegen das öffentliche
Interesse Bef finden in Großbritannien
tragen Geheimhaltung und Komplexität im
Finanzwesen und in der Regierung dazu
bei Korruption in öffentlichen Ämtern zu
verschleiern die Finanzstrukturen sind
oft so komplex dass sie selbst dann wenn
sie öffentlich aufgedeckt werden nicht
als das erkannt werden was sie sind ein
Beispiel dafür ist PFI die private
finance steht
für sich um eine Methode zur
Finanzierung öffentlicher
Infrastrukturen wie Krankenhäuser
Schulen Straßen und Brücken die aber
über den privaten Sektor und nicht wie
bisher über die Zentralregierung
finanziert werden über einen Zeitraum
von 30 oder 40 Jahren sind die
rückzahlungskosten insgesamt drei oder
vier Mal höher als wenn man sich das
Geld von der Zentralregierung leih es
handelt sich also im Grunde um einen
gigantischen
buchhaltungsbetrugald die PFI Politik
eingeführt war stellte man fest dass die
vier großen wirtschaftsprüfungsfirmen
eigentlich bezahlte Mitarbeiter des
Finanzministeriums waren die dann
tatsächlich herumliefen und für die
Umsetzung von PFI Verträgen durch
öffentliche Behörden
sorgten sie sagten kommt zu uns und wir
werden euch zeigen wie ihr den größten
Nutzen daraus ziehen könnt mit anderen
Worten wie man die Gesetzgebung
ausnutzen
kann der staatlichen Steuerbehörde sind
jetzt im Ausland angesiedelt die hmrc
die Steuerbehörde hier in Großbritannien
hat ihre Büros auf den Bermudas und
gehört einer Firma namens Maple
steps das ist ziemlich
unglaublich das Unternehmen das den PFI
Vertrag für den Betrieb des hmrc
hauptbüros besitzt hat sich bei offshore
Investoren Geld zu 15% Zinsen
geliehen da die Zinsen so hoch waren
machte das Unternehmen Verluste und
zahlte daher keine Steuern im Jahr 2011
konnte das hmrc nicht nachweisen dass
irgendein PFI Unternehmen im Vereinigten
Königreich Steuern gezahlt
hat ich glaube wir müssen eine
ernsthafte Diskussion über die Rolle der
Regierung in diesen ganzen Debakel
führen und darüber wie sehr die
Regierungen von großen Banken und
Wirtschaftsprüfungsunternehmen
unterwandert wurden und in wessen
Interesse sie letztendlich handeln
Africa Public Private Partnership
conference London
2015 der Grund für unseren Protest vor
der Afrika PPP Konferenz war dass wir
sicherstellen wollten dass die Bürger in
Afrika davon erfahren dass diese Politik
hier im Vereinten Königreich ein
kompletter Fehlschlag war wirssen
Produkte in den afrikanischen Ländern
nicht in Ihrem eigenen Interesse
vermarktet werden die einzige Motivation
besteht darin die Reichweite von
Finanzdienstleistungen auf neue Märkte
auszudehnen das alles wird im Interesse
der Londoner City geführt was wir hier
erleben ist im Grunde eine zweite Form
der Kolonialisierung zunächst gab es
eine Besetzung und Ressourcengewinnung
und durch diesen Prozess haben Länder
wie Großbritannien die ein großes
offshore Imperium hatten bedeutende
Netzwerke entwickelt und jetzt werden
diese Netzwerke genutzt um finanz
zudern und
auszubeuten die City of London war das
schlagende finanzielle Herz des
britischen
Empire als das Empire unterging wandelte
sich die City von einer Drehscheibe der
finanzmaschinerie des
Empire zu einem globalen finanz
ehemals unbedeutende Außenposten des
Empire wurden zur Grundlage eines
Spinnennetzes von geheimen offshore
Rechtssystemen die den Reichtum aus der
ganzen Welt einfingen und in die City of
Landon leiteten heute werden 25% der
internationalen Finanzgeschäfte auf
britischem Territorium abgewickelt fast
die Hälfte aller geheimen Rechtssysteme
weltweit steht unter britischem Schutz
und etwa die Hälfte des offore Vermögens
könnte in den britischen offshore hen
versteckt
sein im Bereich der
Finanzdienstleistungen verdienen
Großbritanniens Eliten ihr Geld und hier
finden auch ehemalige regierungsminister
hohe Beamte und pensionierte Spione des
MI5 und MI6 nach ihrer Zeit im
öffentlichen Dienst lukrative
beraterstellen gemeinsam haben sie
Großbritannien und seine Dependenzen in
die größte Steueroase der Welt
verwandelt was der Entwicklung in der
ganzen Welt schadet und Großbritannien
selbst in ein Land verwandelt das vor
allem den Interessen seiner Eliten
[Musik]
dient die Abschaffung von Steueroasen
und finanzgeheimnissen ist nicht
unmöglich hier sind fünf Schritte um
Ihnen ein Ende zu setzen verhindern dass
öffentliche Verwaltungen Aufträge an
Unternehmen vergeben die in
Steuerparadiesen tätig sind erstellen
öffentlicher Verzeichnisse der
wirtschaftlichen Eigentümer von
Unternehmen Treuhandgesellschaften und
Stiftungen Einführung vollständiger
Transparenz bei Geschäften und geheimen
Vereinbarungen zwischen Unternehmen und
Regierungen Einführung einer
öffentlichen länderbezogenen
Berichterstattung durch multinationale
Unternehmen Einführung eines aut ischen
Informationsaustausch zwischen allen
[Musik]
Ländern
H